a unos 100 kilómetros de la costa Libia
estos migrantes están en peligro Fueron
avistados por un barco de médicos Sin
fronteras una embarcación neumática
navega hacia las víctimas del naufragio
es un niño es un niño es un niño
quédense ahí este hombre levanta un bebé
sobre sus hombros
con la prioridad de salvar al niño el
bebé de 4 meses ya no respira
quieres que lo lleve Sí por favor
vamos vamos
el periodista que filmó los hechos
relata lo sucedido
ya después de unos segundos que
parecieron horas el bebé empezó a llorar
de nuevo y pudimos continuar la
operación
el personal de salvamento continuó
Rescatando a los adultos que aún no se
habían puesto a salvo tenemos que
moverlo más hacia la parte trasera del
barco vale vamos a ponerlo en el barco
parenme
Está bien dame tu mano
estos migrantes están aterrorizados
muchos no saben nadar 23 de las 100
personas involucradas murieron más tarde
por ahogamiento
el personal de rescate puso a salvo a la
madre del bebé y todos los
supervivientes fueron trasladados al
barco de salvamento
por precaución el bebé y su madre fueron
llevados en helicóptero a un hospital de
Malta